There were so many cool moments this summer and I want to share them with you.
I had several amazing trips.
The longest one took me 18 hours.
I went from the US to Ukraine to a city called Odessa which is located by the Black Sea.
Almost every day, I would ride my bike to the beach.
And I definitely enjoyed lots of swimming with my friends and cousins.
And I loved the boat trip that we took with my family along the seashore of Odessa.
It was fun to see dolphins fooling around in the dolphinarium.
It was a cool show.
Once I even had the chance to swim with dolphins.
It was really fun.
This summer, I even got to be a chef!
I made a yummy pizza.
My cousins did, too.
By the way, did you know that the first pizza in the world was made in Greece.
I had a few train trips around Ukraine.
Me and my family got to go to the Carpathian mountain.
It was super beautiful and fun.
Look at these gigantic trees.
My cousin and I look so tiny comparing to them.